mark Stein is an author and columnist
and he joins us tonight mark
authoritarians it's a little ironic that
these people are calling the population
that while those simultaneously trying
to control the population by any means
necessary
exactly taka and in fact the reason they
wound up with Donald Trump getting
elected president is because they've got
a long tradition of doing this to any
Republic and they did it to Bush they
did it to Mitt Romney who's the very
definition of a milquetoast and yet they
managed to claim that he was some kind
of Nazi because he stuck his dog on the
car and drove the dog to Canada or
whatever it was and in the end in the
end all Trump was the only guy who could
withstand the kind of careless
demonization that goes on and it's
interesting to me you gave all those
examples of the authoritarian trends on
the left there are lots of other ones
too I mean David Gergen didn't get upset
when Sheldon Whitehouse a democrat
senator proposed that people who
disagree with his views on climate
change should be subject to criminal
prosecution sec he didn't worry about
the authoritarian temptation when the
Democrats in the Senate voted
effectively to neuter the First
Amendment
he didn't bemoan the trend towards
authoritarianism when the previous
administration weaponized both the
Justice Department and the IRS to go
after its ideological enemies and worst
of all he didn't he didn't have bemoaned
the trend towards authoritarianism when
dozens of Democrat legislators before
Trump had even set foot in the office
decided to boycott his inauguration
which is the very defining act of a free
society the peaceful transfer of power
David Goggin didn't we
a word when dozens of Democrats decided
they were gonna boycott that
inauguration he seemed deeply
unconcerned I was thinking this weekend
why is it what all these issues have in
common though gun control mass
immigration particularly attacks on the
nuclear family mail headed households
the patriarchy they never let up with
that what is that about and it seems to
me that the family is the final bulwark
against the spread of government power
you're loyal to your family first when
you stop being loyal to your family
first you can be controlled yes and I
would say actually the one of the most
disturbing trends there were there's an
Indian professor in Bangalore who who be
moans the way essentially Western
leftists have nationalized the family
they they started off by you know
nationalizing the the mines and the car
industry and when all that didn't work
they actually figured out its bestest to
cut to the chase and nationalize the
family and you know what matters in any
society is the intervening institutions
between the individual and the
government you mentioned the family you
mentioned the church it's also things
like town government and county
government and when you have serious
revolutions like the Soviets and the
French they abolish all of those in the
Soviet case they did go very far towards
abolishing the family we've got
something slightly different as we've
seen in Florida where you have vast
essentially you've got government Social
Services you've got government police
agencies at multiple levels monitoring
someone and they're actually you know
these these things are not as effective
as in fact a functioning family and
letting parents raise their children as
opposed to having doctors determined
that your seven-year-old is going
through a bit of a phase so let's him
get-get him transitioning into a girl
they're at war with all the intervening
agencies between centralized power and
the individual and it's not an accident
brilliant and now I always learn
something when you're on mark Stein
thank you very much thanks a lot Tucker